[Music]
ruben is with us in corpus christi texas
hi ruben welcome to the ramsay show
good thank you
what's up
hey um yeah me and my wife um had a
situation where
we have an opportunity to purchase a
house
and
right now we have about half of it or a
little more than half
but we can pay it in full if we clear
out her 401k so my question is should i
finance
that difference or should i just get out
of the 401k and just have a free and
clear house
sounds pretty tempting doesn't it
yeah
so if you take it out of the 401k you
get a 10 penalty plus your tax rate so
if your tax rate is 25 that's a 35 hit
on your money
so kind of what you just accidentally
asked me was dave i want to borrow money
at 35 interest
to have a paid for house
and that would that that would be of
course ridiculous wouldn't it okay okay
yeah uh and we said whatever you told us
well i mean no no it's not what i
i want you to think
you don't want to give up 35 of your
money
right it's like 35 interest
okay you understand
yes yes no i do okay i do so we just
borrow it from the bank yeah i assume
you're out of debt everything but the
hou but the house you're buying right
well yes yeah well we owe about 6 000 on
the truck and
30 000 on our car on her car so other
than that we
how much money do you have in savings
um right now a hundred and eight
thousand dollars
okay and what's your household income
about 80
to
90 000 i guess
okay you're probably um
not attuned enough to the things that we
talk about here and we teach for you to
actually do this
but i'm gonna go ahead and tell you
anyway what you should do and what i
would do if i woke up in your shoes i'm
guessing you're in your mid-20s
no i'm actually in uh we had a house
the house was almost paid off but we had
an accident well we didn't have an
accident on january the first a firework
got in my backyard while we were asleep
burned the whole house down we got out
alive thank god but
that happened and that's why we're in
this situation we're in uh we were
already paying off our house i mean how
old are you
i'm 47. oh okay all right all right
um
what we teach folks is your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income so getting out of debt and
staying out of debt
first step is everything but the house
then the house
um and when you make you said eighty
thousand dollars a year
well between the yeah yeah well i would
say closer to 90 to 100 000 really i
guess well i mean what'd you pay taxes
on dude do you not know
um yes i paid on 55
she paid on i want to say 40 so
i i think that's about like 95. okay so
30 000 car does not fit in this equation
you have too much tied up in something
that's going down in value no it doesn't
fit at all i would sell it right
again i'd get a cheaper car
and i would pay them both off and with
what's left i would put it all down on
the house
and i would put the house on a 15-year
fixed rate or less and then i would work
on paying down the house because you
have no debt at that point
but
you shouldn't have more than half your
annual income and you potentially do are
very close to it tied up in things that
go down in value with wheels and motors
so the chances of you calling about a
401k withdrawal and me selling your 30
000 car in the same conversation are
fairly low i know that but it is still
what you should do
um and i hope i can convince you to
think about that anyway because if i
woke up in your shoes knowing what i
know now with all the stupid butt stuff
i have done in my life uh i and if you
were to talk to one of the 10 000
millionaires that were in the
millionaire survey that we did for the
baby steps millionaires book
you would find that they would all say
the biggest mistakes they've ever made
are super expensive cars when they're
still broke and you are still broke
you're not broken like most people but
you don't have any money to mount
anything
um you're just still in your early
stages of wealth building and so you
need to get those cars cleared up the
best thing to do is i would rather you
be driving a ten thousand dollar car and
have another 20 on down on the house
then you keep this 20 30 car and pay
down on it personally if i was in your
shoes that's what i would do
and so i'd have a couple ten thousand
dollar cars i'd put as much down on this
house i could get it paid off and then
you're gonna be in a position to really
super build wealth
but uh again i think i just sold mom's
car so i don't know if i'm gonna get
away with that or not yeah you you three
hit a lot hit a lot there dave the
thirty thousand dollar car
i gotta sell that but it makes total
sense especially if uh if if you can
come out ahead on that and then put that
towards the other cars i think he said
six thousand in credit card debt as well
i was on the other car it was the other
car okay yeah so knocking that out is
going to be huge
and here's the other thing uh you you
uh need to think about in this case
reuben is
car debt
is debt
you weren't sure of that early in the
conversation
so it's like oh we don't we're we're
having debt but we got these two guard
debts 30 000 and 6 000 that's that it's
a debt because if you don't pay it they
will repossess your butt and then they
will sue your butt and that's what will
happen and yeah so it's debt it's going
to has
consequences has problems